hallo ihr lieben würden wir heute mal
einen bock auf meinem kanal
es steht etwas ganz besonderes an und
weil es so einzigartig ist nicht zum
ersten mal im leben mache habe ich
gedacht das möchte ich vermeiden
youtube kanal gerne festhalten über
instagram hat das mit sicherheit
mitbekommen wir haben ein bug event
geplant das heißt gebe meinen
allerersten backkurs ich weiß noch nicht
genau was mich erwartet aber ich hab
ganz viel geplant und diese planung
style überspringen wir jetzt einfach ist
es gerade einen tag vor dem kurs und wir
werden es erleben wir werden jetzt noch
mal die letzten dinge besorgen
dafür geben wir jetzt einkaufen
natürlich mit dem einzigartigen langsam
mit saphir mich richtig aufgeregt aber
trotzdem mitnehmen
trotz der aufregung wie das alles so
abläuft upgrades abgeht
was packe ich euch von indigo liberg mal
gucken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist die location für morgen
ach ja markus mit familie mal nach von
waldkirchen und ich werde erstmal das
abladen
[Musik]
die zwei beruflich will
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin echt müde versuche heute früh
schlafen zu gehen und nicht nur morgen
ganz früh im küchenstudio sein und alles
abzuwägen und vorzubereiten und ich habe
mir aus der kiko eine mitarbeiterin
jahren
da siehst du was mitarbeiterin des
monats ist vielen noch zu hilfe geholt
dass die ja zwischendurch einfach auch
mal ein bisschen hier ist wenn die mal
weg zu räumen ist aber so ich bin
gespannt bis morgen ja morgen jetzt
haben wir zwei varianten im reiten alles
fürs backen vor haben wir super
motiviert weil er mit button wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei den muffins habe ich jetzt ein
rezept genommen wo wir halt keine
küchenmaschine brauchen
ich weiß nicht wer macht das von euch zu
hause gearbeitet mit küchenmaschinen
lieber einmal die hand hoch okay okay
aber es sind halt doch auch viele die es
nicht machen und das ist so ein rezept
da muss man einfach nur rühren und
deswegen kann ich das für heute so
praktisch
[Musik]
nein
genau die jahren verteilt auch gerade
schon die spritzbeutel da könnt euch die
türen schon mal angucken
entscheidet ihr euch dann auch für eine
bestimmte farbe
[Musik]
aber ich wusste ja auch ein partner sie
noch einfach so und dann natürlich dann
praktisch sie können noch gucken was für
eine tolle ihr vorne dran
wir haben eine platine sterntaler und
eine rosenschule könnte einfach schauen
welche farbe ihre waffen möchte
[Musik]
und am besten schon runter drücken mit
möglichst wenig luft mehr dass man das
sowieso und nicht immer wieder öffnet ja
so wichtig genau
[Musik]
rosenmüller die rosenthal ist die die
nach innen so ein bisschen gebeugt ist
da kann man ja ganz gut so große rosen
spritzen entweder von außen nach innen
oder von innen nach außen dass es auch
euch überlassen oder ihr macht nur
tapfer
ja und mit der sterne finde ich kann man
auch ganz gut machen aber also im
prinzip seite da komplett frei
ihr habt noch bei der glatten 1 jahr so
ein klein live-act bin ich immer ganz
gerne benutzer entweder halte ich halte
ich den finger hatte ich hier unten an
seite oder ich krebs mit tesa bandes
könnt ihr gleich auch mal probieren und
dann wieder vom markt
und dann mache ich da so bemängelte
linien
[Musik]
von der mitte nach außen so ok weiter
weiß halte ja und loslassen
[Gelächter]
dieses einzigartige zwischen ich kann es
mir zu packen ganz schön was los ist
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
so dann komme nicht an sondern zum
abschluss auch jetzt richtig spaß
gemacht wird euch also war für mich auch
mein erster bacchus und ja mit so lieben
teilnehmern ganz schön weh dass ich
wirklich ein schöner tag für mich und
ich hoffe euch jetzt auch gefallen nimmt
er auch sie wird von heute
ich habe mit kaufland zusammen haben wir
euch noch eine schöne gudiberg
zusammengestellt mich ganz so darauf
einigen was drin ist soll eine
überraschung sein für euch zu hause und
die schützen dürfte auch gerne behalten
die meisten einfach direkt in die welt
mit rein und danke auch an kauf werden
auch mal an der stelle für die schöne
möglichkeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]